star wars battlefront is getting its
outer rim DLC expansion this month and
now we know what's coming with it I'm
Tony and this is your gamespot news
update from a galaxy far far away to new
heroes are making their way to the
battlefield grito and Nia nub were shown
in the teaser art and now they're
confirmed as playable heroes we don't
know what abilities they'll have but
I've got a feeling grito will be able to
shoot first we're also getting a bunch
of new weapons the rebbe v10 rifle d t12
blaster pistol scattergun dioxis grenade
and adrenaline stim you'll be able to
test those out on two new maps on the
planets Tatooine and Sullust last but
certainly not least outer rim includes a
new game mode called extraction the
rebels have to transport a shipment of
resources to a particular point and the
Empire has to stop them along the way
the outer rim expansion is included in
star wars battlefront $50 season pass
it's one of four total expansions coming
to the game will definitely tell you all
about the rest of that dlc once we get
the details I'm Tony Wilson you can
follow me on twitter at chain-gun Pope
and may the force be with you